let's do that let's use that to jump
into this next story which uh i i pulled
up the best source imaginable for this
is the independent women's forum
they say feminist author and former bill
clinton advisor naomi wolf warns of
totalitarianism
because of pandemic emergency rules it's
really interesting because
naomi wolf voted for joe biden then came
out later saying if i had known he was
in favor of lockdowns i wouldn't have
done it
the dude was screaming high heavens he
was in favor of lockdown he was the
plexiglass
president yeah literally that was what
he was named after
so it was surprising to see this kind of
tweet it did go viral because it did
garner a lot of attention
but you know there's a lot of things we
could criticize them but this is a
moment where she's finally coming out
and actually speaking some bigger truths
out there she was just on tucker carlson
and some of the points she's making are
ryan on the head and i have to agree
with her when she says that lockdowns
are
as the mexican president said tools of
totalitarians what i find interesting
about this
is one i will always give credit where
credit is due
calling out totalitarianism and the
lockdowns and all stuff is a good thing
but i do have to at least have some
critical view
i mean does she really care or is she
just making money off of
anti-establishment sentiment
when it was trump in office trump was
bad and then immediately the day
after they call it for biden she goes oh
oh oh oh biden is bad too
uh yeah dude like the reason i bring
this up is because luke you made that
point about strippers
that you know the people who trust
politicians are the same people who
think that strippers like them
is naomi wolfe just another one of these
personalities who's going to try and say
whatever she has to say
i would contest that from my own
personal experiences understanding that
the anti-establishment dollar
is not really a high dollar it's not
really valued a lot and now the
the establishment dollar which means
talking about their narratives and their
talking points that pays a lot that has
a lot of gigs so
i think she's actually putting a lot on
the line by criticizing biden because
she's one of the few that actually does
and there's not many other people like
her
and i don't think i honestly think she
didn't know the um
my wife's parents my in-laws i guess you
call them
because they're from iran cnn has
actually good reputation internationally
the biggest problem with cnn isn't
domestic because internationally people
actually believe that stuff
and it really is harming the country in
the country's interests
so they don't know they'll come over and
bring up things and we're like
yeah you know that this thing happened i
have no idea that it happened
so i do believe people like naomi wolf
are so secluded
that she didn't know i mean something
came out too robbie so i've uh tweeted
it out i think skeptic mag did the
survey but
if you ask most violent voters how many
unarmed black men do you think are
killed a year
by police they're going to say a
thousand yeah i think we actually we
actually
have this there's a set you tweeted
about that zach goldberg tweeted about
it
interestingly there's this graph i also
posted on instagram
they asked people in 2019 what
percentage of people killed by police
were black
very liberal people said 60 percent they
thought 60 percent of the people killed
by police were black conservatives said
37
the real number 23 even conservatives
were overestimating but the crazy thing
you're referencing
is in one of the graphs if you ask a
very liberal person
how many black men were killed by cops
in 2019 31
of very liberals will say about one
thousand
thirty percent will say about one
hundred and then among conservatives
forty six percent say about ten forty
percent say about a hundred
i think the real number was uh 20 20 17
years yeah
and that's where you know this is what
probably where the mindset work comes in
is
a lot of persuasion or mindset is
meeting people where they are
so i know that if i'm talking to a biden
person like naomi wolfe
i'm meeting her where she is which she
believes that literally there's a
thousand
unarmed black people being killed and
that's why they're so
you know because i'd be freaking out too
if there were a thousand unarmed black
people being killed a year in the
country
i would be marching with them too right
i would i would be right there but when
you actually look at you're like well
i mean it's 19 to 25. twice as many
white people are actually killed
nobody knows their names there's
actually a bit of that in the hoax movie
was
ask how many people name one white guy
who was killed
the best i can do is i think it was in
san bernardino a homeless guy got beat
to death and you could see the pictures
of his face swollen up
but that's the closest that i can come
to finding the name
right even though numerically we should
know at least as many but we really
don't
so when you look at the numbers you have
a different perspective
on how things are going so you have to
meet people where they are this is what
they believe
so this could just be naomi wolfe
getting the red pill
basically she's been she's been eating
up mainstream media trash
and then something happened after the
seventh where she saw some news that she
trusted and said
wait a minute what and she finally woke
up to what was really going on well
she's been
anti-establishment for a while she also
uh said a lot of supportive things for
the second amendment and and told people
to reconsider their thoughts on the left
about
uh being able to defend yourself and
bear arms i interviewed her before
so there is a shifting but i think again
we we have to stop thinking between the
left and the right we have to start
thinking establishment versus
anti-establishment
and overall i think she's been on the
anti-establishment
trend and i think should be some someone
interesting to talk to about this
specifically so crazy to get into her
mind and understand where she came from
and what changes her opinions you just
said it's anti-establishment to support
the second amendment
the the most established document in the
united states somehow is
anti-establishment
that's true that's insane yeah every one
of these politicians are doing
everything in their power to destroy it
because it constrains them then it
sounds like they're not in our best
interests
it's it's like over the past several
hundred years the the people have had a
giant
shield the constitution and every day a
politician
is just battering against it trying to
destroy it and justify
their their ability to do so if we don't
i guess uh i don't know i don't know the
exact quote
if we don't defend the constitution then
the constitution will no longer defend
us
it's just like multinational corporate
bribes yeah
but in that uh in that regard nami wolf
is absolutely correct about the
totalitarianism
and i'm glad at least some people are
waking up to it joe biden
is going to be doing all of these things
that they complained about that
with trump you know kids in cages
congratulations that's all back
it's actually back with a vengeance now
they've got more facilities
before it was donald trump using was it
the homestead facility in in in southern
miami
and that was built on the obama
administration right they complained
about it and now lord and as a lawyer
too not to interrupt just to chime in
it's
under the law they actually have to that
was something left out of the reporting
there was something called the flores
decision
which is that you can't keep kids and
adults together in the same facility
so the whole thing as you said started
with obama because of this ninth circuit
ruling
carried under trump and biden's doing it
but it's like but
it's not just that so so trump inherits
the homestead facility and the left is
screaming and complaining he's got kids
in cages
and they kept accidentally posting
photos of obama era stuff
but joe biden just he opened a new one
didn't he they have these new
these new uh mobile units with bars on
the windows
they look like an air conditioner yeah
overflow facilities overflow
migrant youth overflow facility now
here's a funny thing
i'm gonna defend joe biden on this one
when donald trump
uh under his administration you had
these kids being separated from the
adults
we don't know who their parents are
right so do you really want these kids
to potentially be with strangers because
strangers do that
sometimes it's horrifying we want to
make sure families are not separated
but what if you have some dude who can't
prove who his kid is and the kid says
that's not my dad
so they separate the kids and then the
life gets mad joe biden
is doing the same thing the left is
complaining about joe biden doing this
now and i'm going to say the same thing
we can't just assume because some guy
said that's my kid
it's that's true and we got to be
careful about trafficking so what do we
do
yeah being in mexico many times you see
all these wanted posters and all these
missing children posters
all over the public streets and there's
an epidemic of missing children
in mexico that's a lot higher than a lot
of people even understand
and covering the border crisis
specifically in tijuana there's been
many stories of children being stolen
so they could use it as a way to get
across the border and to get sympathy
and there's this fake news being spread
around that if you come across the
border with it with a child that you're
going to be allowed in
allowed through without any problems
without any questions as long as you
have a child so
there's stories like this it's not
always uh you know the the
it doesn't always 100 of the time happen
but it does happen and it does need to
be addressed
and sadly this you know the child
trafficking and kidnapping in mexico
deserves to be a lot of a bigger story
than it actually is
i guess the the main issue with
everything we've been talking about is
people
you look you said it was establishment
versus anti-establishment
i don't even think that's true i think
it's people who only watch mainstream
media versus people who actually think
critically
zombies well you have to look deep
though i mean
again you know i have a lot of
compassion for people it's just
imagine if you don't go into the weeds
to look
into everything yourself it's like a
full-time job practically
so that's that's why you know the they
attack youtube and everything else is
the idea that that you're a working mom
or a working dad and you come home after
a long shift and you've got three hours
and you hope to see your kids before
they go to bed
and you're gonna say oh i wonder what
really is going on with these overflow
facilities oh there was actually a
ruling called the flores decision you
can't have unaccompanied minors because
human trafficking and there was a report
actually
to your point luke there was actually a
report that showed that hundreds of
children had been
human trafficked and had been let go
back to their traffickers so that this
is all
not conspiracy it's all true but you're
just trying to get by
man you're just trying to live and
that's why i
i think that's because i grew up very
poor i think that's why i loathe the
media in a way that i take it personally
which is
people are just trying to work man
people are just trying to get by people
are trying to live the best life that
they can and be moral
and be compassionate and you're lying to
them you're creating hysteria
you're making people think that if
you're a black guy and you leave your
house
you might be hunted down by the police
that day because thousands of people are
being killed every day
you're creating a horrible horrible
mental state for people
and i resent that trauma fear pain and
once you put that in someone's mindset
once you attract that once you make them
think that they're a victim
i mean they're going to start acting
like it and your mindset is
critically uh important that's why you
know you wrote your book this way but
another thing that that kind of gave me
hope recently and i started my video
today with this
was a clip from the australian open and
it's a clip of a lady
talking about how great the vaccine is
and we're all going to go back to normal
because of the vaccine and the crowd
erupted
really huge booze at the australian open
and then she said
we want to thank our government bigger
booze bigger i
i tweeted the video also uh lukewarm
change if you want to pull it up but the
video is
eye-opening and mind-boggling to see so
many people during the australian open
just absolutely boo as loud as they can
this person trying to thank the
government and the vaccine for bringing
life back to normal and it was something
that
literally awe struck me and made me
really consider like hey maybe maybe
people are far more awake than we
than we understand um i don't know if
you could play the full clip because
yeah copy copyrights
oh yeah maybe not uh you should be
careful with that but
uh when you play the video i mean the
booze are so
loud there's there's no even questioning
it i think you played the first 15
seconds
an extraordinary sacrifice for everyone
and with vaccinations on the way
rolling out in many countries around the
world it's now a time for optimism and
hope for the future
yeah wow it was even bigger booze when
she was like we want to thank the
government they
they even went crazier but don't play
the full clip because you know you've
got to be careful
but seeing that clip gave me chills
because it's like wait wait people are
are far more awake people are far more
aware than we give them credit
to and we're seeing a perception of
reality that's catered to us by
algorithms by big tech billionaires
and that's another perspective you need
to entertain thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you